durante un parto vaginal la primera
etapa del trabajo de parto dura de 12 a
19 horas y se inicia cuando su bebé se
mueve hacia su pelvis y se coloca ahí
como respuesta el cuello uterino se
empieza a borrar o volverse más delgado
y dilatar o ensanchar durante este
proceso usted puede sentir contracciones
fuertes y regulares que ocurren cada 5 a
20 minutos además de dolor lumbar y
cólicos que no desaparecen es posible
que vea un flujo mucoso amarronado o
rojizo el cual puede ser el tapón mucoso
que se desprende de la abertura de su
cuello uterino su saco amniótico puede
romperse el cual puede ser una abundante
chorro de agua o un goteo continuo si
experimenta alguno de estos síntomas
comuníquese con su médico o partera para
saber si debe ir al hospital al comienzo
de la segunda etapa del parto que puede
durar de unos minutos a tres horas el
cuello uterino se dilata por completo
hasta los 10 centímetros y la cabeza de
su bebé se ha movido más allá de la
abertura cervical hacia su canal de
parto durante esta etapa usted comenzará
a empujar a su bebé hacia afuera puede
que empuje instintivamente cuando sienta
la necesidad o puede que necesite que su
médico o partera o enfermera de trabajo
de parto le indique cuándo empujar y
cuando descansar en un parto normal la
cabeza de su bebé girará y se
posicionará mirando a su espalda
durante el trabajo de parto su útero se
divide en un segmento activo que se
contrae empujando al bebé hacia abajo y
un segmento pasivo flexible que se
mantiene relajado estirándose para dar
más espacio para que pase su bebé
en algunos casos cuando la parte
superior de la cabeza de su bebé aparece
o se asoma su médico puede hacer un
pequeño corte llamado episiotomía para
agrandar la abertura vaginal luego usted
continuará empujando a su bebé hacia
afuera
puesto que la cabeza de su bebé pasa a
través del canal de parto esta toma una
forma alargada una cabeza alargada se
solucionará por sí sola dentro de unos
días ya que los huesos del cráneo
regresan a su lugar
después de que la cabeza de su bebé sale
por el canal de parto su cabeza y
hombros giran para ayudar a que pasen
por el canal de parto
a los hombros de su bebé pasan uno
después del otro a fin de pasar por su
pelvis
una vez que salen los hombros el resto
de su bebé sale fácilmente
después del nacimiento de su bebé se le
cortará su cordón umbilical en la
tercera etapa del trabajo de parto la
cual puede durar de 5 a 30 minutos unas
suaves contracciones ayudarán a empujar
la placenta fuera del útero durante esta
etapa es posible que usted y su bebé
empiecen a crear lazos afectivos
mediante el contacto piel con piel y el
amamantamiento